überraschende wende im diesel skandal
freunde angela merkel will jetzt wohl
doch hardware nachrüstung für dreckige
diesel stellt sich nur noch eine frage
hart wer soll das bezahlen
vw und die anderen betrüger sagen wir
sicher nicht und was sagt unser
verkehrsminister an die scheuer an die
wo steckt er denn wieder sehen sie mich
geht nicht ich bin im toten winkel du
dann bleibt doch da ja letzten
donnerstag hat ihm die kanzlerin gesagt
er komme aus den puschen in sachen
diesel wir haben bei den landtagswahlen
die leute sind sauer
also stellt sich der andy fürs handy und
wendet sich an sein volk
ich werde ein konzept ausarbeiten ach du
scheiße wo wir zum einen uns gedanken
machen wie ein umstieg möglich ist in
ein neues fahrzeug und wir werden uns
technische gedanken machen wie wir
bestehende fahrzeuge noch sauberer
bekommen noch sauberer wenn man das geht
doch gar nicht
der wahnsinn bis sonntag muss er sich
jetzt etwas konkretes einfallen lassen
sagt frau merkel es gemeint meine der
scheuer wollte sich doch einfach mal
unverbindlich ich zitiere technische
gedanken machen hier geschenktipp dein
papa wasser tobt sich einen diesel zu
kaufen und könnte ich jetzt nicht mehr
zur schule bringen
dann hol dir jetzt den neuen
experimentierkasten technische gedanken
1000 tolle ideen von unserem
verkehrsminister bastl aus nur 300.000
klopapierrollen einen extra langen
auspuff der den dreck in die
stratosphäre bläst genial oder bau dir
einen eigenen coolen dieselfilter zb mit
mamas staubsauger und die beste idee mit
dem anbieter brecheisen klaus doodle
fetten benziner vom nachbarn beschließt
ihn kurz und fährst einfach selber zur
schule
geil technische daten mit andy für
kleine klugscheißer ab sechs jahren
ist ja bald weihnachten
ja
die meldung meldung von gestern ganz
aktuelle adac langzeittest beweisen die
nachrüstung von euro 5 diesel mit
sogenannten scr katalysatoren reduziert
den stickoxidausstoß um 50 bis 70
prozent und kostet zwischen 1500 und
3000 euro
heuer wollte trotzdem lieber die und ich
zitiere wörtlich erneuerung der diesel
flotte eine flotte also euro 5 diesel
fahrer sollen sich gefälligst einen euro
6 kaufen und dafür gibt es dann rabatt
vielleicht noch ein konjunkturprogramm
für betrügerische autohersteller gibt es
doch gar nicht was mir gefällt muss ich
ehrlich sagen ist scheiders
internetauftritt da zeigt er uns sein
ministerium und hat's rätselhafte weise
sehr eilig los gehts minister garten
durch die gänge
durch den erich klausener saal
wunderschöner saal im übrigen warum
warum andererseits natürlich ein gutes
training das ganze gerede
ich sage mal wenn im nächsten jahr in
frankfurt das fahrverbot kommt dann muss
der andere ja wahrscheinlich vor einer
heute von diesen fahrern weglaufen ne
wii 2
würde sagen da sind wir alle mal sehr
gespannt was da am sonntag kommt bis
jetzt spielen hersteller und politik vor
allem auf zeit wir schalten live zu
dennis knossalla von knossalla das mega
seriöser volkswagen busse der knossalla
obmann vw juristisch zwingen kann
nachzurüsten ist er umstritten aber
merkel hat den menschen hoffnung gemacht
da hat unsere mitarbeiterin die frau
merkel leider voreilig was ausgepowert
ist noch nicht so lange im autogeschäft
[Gelächter]
ich sage ihnen was ich danke gott auf
knie für diesen dieser skandal gibt mir
seinen toren vor 2012 in zahlung weil
der die grenzwerte reißen und dann kauft
er sich den euro 6 trägt der auch
beschiss software kauft weiter bei vw
keine würde ich persönlich wird ja nie
wieder was kaufen was auch nur an
wolfsburg vorbeigefahren ist was ist
verfasst dich die kasse ist da hinten
gibt's denn jetzt noch hardware
nachrüstung oder nicht
was kostja geld ja vw hat im letzten
jahr gerade mal elf milliarden gewinn
gemacht wer soll denn das bezahlen
und frau merkel geht es doch nur um die
landtagswahlen im oktober
wir müssen jetzt die doofen noch ein
paar wochen bei laune halten hier jeder
depp der immer noch mal mehr kauft
kriegt unser vw trost paket was haben
wir denn da durch baum- und den an die
scheuer rallye kalender
theresa wieder die alte pflaume und er
hat den neuen vertrag nicht
unterschrieben
[Gelächter]
ich frag mich was muss ich noch machen
damit diese idioten aufhören meine
karten zu kaufen
auf den sitz packen sollte frau bumsen
alles schon probiert wissen sie was ich
würde sie verklagen ja mach doch
sämtliche ansprüche gegen uns händler
sind schon ende 2017 verjährt hat der
verkennt die page will so gegen den
hersteller kann ich doch noch bis ende
2018 klagen ja da ist natürlich haben
sie dass ich jetzt da ich taste heidi
klum nackt im cabrio
denn es knossalla meine damen und herren
[Applaus]
[Musik]